اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مقابله خاصه مع
رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسيه الدكتور رشاد
العليمي للحديث عن دعم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه للشعب اليمني والجهود التي
تبذلها الرياض لوقف الحرب واحلال السلام
مرحبا بكم سياده الرئيس اهلا وسهلا ياتي
افتتاح وتدشين حزمه من المشاريع للبرامج
السعودي في عدن في ظل جهود سياسيه حديثه
تبدلها الرياض
لوقف الحرب واحلال السلام ما دلالات هذا
التوقيت واهميه هذه المشاريع في هذه
المرحله اولا اهلا وسهلا بالعربيه نحن
دائما نتطلع
لان نكون مع العربيه دائما
وشكرا لكل جهودكم التي تدعمون فيها المجلس
القياده الرئاسي والحكومه والشعب اليمني
فيما يتعلق بموضوع المشاريع اليوم لا شك
ان هناك دلالات كثيره
لتنشين وافتتاح هذه المشاريع اولا تعرفون
ان البرنامج السعودي بدا في 2018 ولا شكل
ان هذا البرنامج عندنا بدا كان هناك
الكثير من التحديات والصعوبات وكثير من
المشاريع تحتاج الى مسح
وتحتاج الى تخطيط وتحتاج الى دراسات
واعتقد ان هناك
متطلبات
لانجاز الكثير من هذه المشاريع سواء من
حيث التخطيط او من حيث التنفيذ وهذا
يستغرق وقت طويل اليوم النتيجه كانت
والثمره لهذه السنوات الاربع هو افتتاح
وتدشين هذا العدد الكبير من المشاريع على
مستوى عدن كعاصمه مؤقته وعاصمه الاقتصاديه
ايضا وعلى مستوى المحافظات اليمنيه
المحرره
وبالتالي هذا التزامن انا اعتقد انه وضع
طبيعي
من خلال الوقت الذي اخذوا البرنامج لكي
يقوم بانجاز مثل هذه المشاريع الدلاله
المهمه جدا في هذا الظرف وهي رساله قويه
للمليشيات الحوثيه
الارهابيه بان الشعب اليمني يريد السلام
الشعب اليمني لا يريد
مزيد من الطائرات المسيره ولا يريد مزيد
من العنف ولا يريد مزيد من الالغام الشعب
اليمني يحتاج للسلام ويحتاج الى الصحه
ويحتاج الى الخدمات ويحتاج الى الطرقات
ويحتاج الى الحياه لا يحتاج الشعب اليمني
يتطلع للحيوانات هل استطاع البرنامج
السعودي وكذلك مركز الملك سلمان للتخفيف
من معاناه الشعب اليمني في ظل هذا الدمار
كما اشرتم من قبل ميليشيات الحوثي
اولا انا اريد ان نكمل السؤال الاول فيما
يتعلق بالنتيجه النهائيه ان ان الدلاله
الرئيسيه لهذا التزامن مع السلام هي رساله
رساله ليست فقط الميليشيات الحوثيه وانما
ايضا لدعمها النظام الايراني الدعم لها ان
الشعب لان ان من يدعمنا اليوم في التحالف
العربي بقياده المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يدعمون
بالصحه ويدعمون بالطرقات ويدعمون بكل
المجالات
في سواء في المشاريع او في اللقاثه من
خلال مركز الملك سلمان وبالتالي انا اعتقد
هذه الرساله مهمه جدا في هذه اللحظه يجب
ان
يلتقطها الشعب اليمني اولا سواء في مناطق
المحرره او في المناطق الخاضعه الحوثيين
وهي رساله قويه ايضا الميليشيات الحوثيه
اننا نريد الحياه ونريد المزيد من
المشاريع والتنميه سياده الرئيس المشاريع
التي
اليوم تم انجازها من قبل البرنامج السعودي
والمشاريع التي ما زالت قيد التنفيذ في
عدن لاعاده التاهيل عدن كعصب مؤقته لليمن
ما مدى التنسيق بين الحكومه اليمنيه
والقائمه على هذا البرنامج لتنفيذ او لجعل
اولويات المشاريع هي السباقه في هذه
المرحله البرنامج هو تم انشاءه بناء على
اتفاق مع الحكومه اليمنيه
وطبعا لا شك ان الحكومه اليمنيه تقوم
بتنسيق مباشر مع البرنامج في عده اتجاهات
الاتجاه الاول في تحديد الاولويات اولويات
المناطق واحتياجاتها ماذا تحتاج عدد مثلا
على سبيل المثال موضوع مستشفى عدن مستشفى
عدن الذي
سيستوعب في حدود نصف مليون
مريض خلال العام هذا سيعمل نقله نوعيه جدا
في المجال الصحي نحن فعلا في حاجه لانه
الحرب التي فجرتها الميليشي
الحوثيه دمرت كل البنيه التحتيه ما في ذلك
البنيه الصحيه وبالتالي كان هناك اولويه
بالنسبه لان يكون هناك مستشفى بهذه
الضخامه وبهذه الامكانيات لكي يستوعب
الحالات المرضيه على مستوى اليمن كلها
اليوم نحن شاهدنا في المستشفى حالات ليست
من عدن فقط ولكن هناك ايضا من المحافظات
المجاوره وبالتالي هذه الاولويات بتحددها
الحكومه بتنسيق مع البرنامج السعودي
للبناء واعاده الاعمال
واعتقد ان هذا التنسيق والتكامل بين
الحكومه وبين البرنامج هو الذي ادى الى
النتائج المثمره التي وصلنا اليها في
تنفيذ هذه المشاريع والتنسيق في كل
المحافظات اليمنيه تنفيذ في المحافظات في
المحافظات المحرره يتم من خلال السلطات
المحليه نحن اليوم نتوجه الى ان يكون هناك
صلاحيات
وفقا للمخرجات الحوار وفقا ايضا حتى
لقانون السلطان المحليه هناك صلاحيات
ممنوحه
للسلطات المحليه في كثير من المجالات ونحن
اليوم نوجه الحكومه في مجلس القياده
الرئاسي ان يعطوا صلاحيه كامله
للسلطات المحليه من خلال المحافظين
والمكاتب التنفيذيه في المحافظات ان
يقوموا بدورهم على المستوى المحلي لانه
تعرف انه نحن اعدنا بناء المؤسسات في عدن
ولكن هذه المؤسسات لم تكتمل بعد وبالتالي
نحن في حاجه الى مؤسسات المحليه ان تقوم
بدور في حاله ضعف الدوله المركزي
للمؤسسات
المركزيه مشاريع الاصلاح الاقتصاديه التي
تنفذها الحكومه اليمنيه للحفاظ على قيمه
الريال اليمني والتي حظيت بدعم سعودي سخي
هل استفادت الحكومه من هذا الدعم وخاصه
الوديعه السعوديه الاماراتيه وكذلك
المشاريع الاخرى مثل المنح النفطيه وكذلك
الطاقه الحكومه
اتخذت برنامج اقتصادي
عملت برنامج اقتصادي وهذا البرنامج
الاقتصادي يهتم بالتنسيق ايضا مع الاخوان
الاشقاء في التحالف دعم الشرعيه وخاصه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والامارات
العربيه المتحده
والبرنامج طبعا الان بيشرف عليه صندوق
النقد العربي اللي مقر في ابوظبي
وهذا البرنامج الان يقوم برقابه على
الصندوق يقوم الان بالرقابه على هذا
البرنامج بالتنسيق مع الحكومه
ونحن ايضا عملنا برنامج يصبح اقتصادي
داخلي املنا برنامج اصلاح اقتصادي واريد
اليوم ايضا اننا بصدد عمل برنامج اصلاح
اداري
نحن لسنا في حاجه فقط الى برنامج اقتصادي
لاصلاح اقتصادي ولكن نحن في حاجه الى
برنامج اصلاح اداري اليوم لانه هناك ضعف
في اداء المؤسسات سواء على المستوى
المركزي والمستوى المحلي نتيجه للظروف
والاوضاع
المتعدده طبعا لا نستطيع شرحها الان ولكن
اليوم نحن بصدد الاعداد لبرنامج اصلاح
اداري سيعرض على مجلس القياده الرئاسي ثم
بعد ذلك نناقشه مع الحكومه
ونقوم بعد ذلك
بالتوجيه الحكومه والتنبيه هذا البرنامج
خلال هذه المرحله التي
قدمت السعوديه هذا الوديعه والامارات كذلك
هل هناك خطوات او استفاده للحد من هذا
التدهور الريال اليمني والحفاظ على قيمه
الريال عندما تشكل مجلس القياده الرئاسي
كان
السعر الصرف
1800 ريال للدولار للدولار اليوم لمده عام
من حين تشكل مجلس القياده الرئاسي وحتى
اليوم
وثبتنا سعر الصرف في حدود ما بين 1100 الى
200 بالكثير ما يتجاوز 1250 هذا في حد
ذاته وانجاز انجاز الحكومه وانجاز للمجلس
القياده الرئاسي وهذا ينعكس على حياه
المواطنين المعيشيه بشكل مباشر نحن بنقوم
اليوم البنك المركزي ومجلس الاداره التقيت
معهم انها في الاشهر الماضيه
ويقومون بدور ايجابي جدا البنك المركزي
اليوم هناك شهادات دوليه على ان البنك
المركزي اليوم يقوم بدور اصلاح اقتصادي
ونقدي ومصرفي فاعل بالتعاون مع وزاره
الماليه والحكومه وهذا هو الذي ادى الى
ثبات
ثبات سعر الصرف في هذا الحدود خلال العام
انت تعرف وطبعا بفضل ما الذي قدم لنا من
الاخوه الاشقه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات العربيه المتحده وخاصه
دعم المشتقات النفطيه الذي يحل مشكله
الكهرباء في في محافظه عدن وبعض المحافظات
والمحافظات المحرره لانه نحن نتطلع الى ان
نتخلص من الطاقه المشتراه على بدايه العام
القادم ويكون لدينا ايضا انتاج طاقه
متعدده متعدده يعني ومنها الطاقه المتجدده
الكهرباء
وخاصه مع فصل الصيف صحيح صحيح احنا لدينا
الان الاخوان الاماراتيين بينفذوا لنا
مشروع 120 ميجا للطاقه الشمسيه لعدم وهذا
المشروع الان ماشي على قدم النساق
وبالتالي انا اتوقع انه على بدايه العام
القادم سيكون يعني حلينا جزئيا مشكله
الكهرباء لانه تعرف هذه المشاريع
الاستراتيجيه تحتاج الى وقت طويل لانجازها
طبعا نحن ماجورين في هذا الامر والمشروع
السعودي بينفذ جزء اليوم الفاقد يصل 40%
في الكهرباء في عدن بسبب الردائس الشبكه
بسبب رداءه الشبكه اليوم المشروع السعودي
الان بينفذ شبكه الضغط العالي والضغط
المنخفض بتمويل من البرنامج وهذا سيحل لنا
مشكله كبيره جدا واليوم ايضا تحدثنا فيه
مع الاخ السفير ومع الفريق البرنامج هناك
جهود السعوديه مكثفه تبدلها الرياض لوقف
الشامل للحرب في اليمن واحلال السلام وهذا
المسار يبدو اليوم اكثر حيويه انتم في
مجلس القياده الرئاسي كيف تتفاعلون مع هذا
الجهد السعودي وهل الطرف الاخر يعني
الحوثي ممكن ان تكون ملتزمه حتى تكون هناك
فرصه تبنى عليها حل او يبنى عليها حل
سياسي
اخي العزيز السلام هو اليمنيين اصلا
السلام في الاساس اليمنيين ومجلس القياده
الرئاسي هو بيمثل اليمنيين وبالتالي انا
اعتقد انه يجب ان نكون نحن احرص من غيرنا
على عمليه السلام ونشكر جهود الاخوان في
المملكه جهود ممتازه وجهود طيبه ونحن
باركناها في مجلس القياده الرئاسي
والحكومه
ومتعاونين تماما مع الدوره السعودي
كوسيط للوصول الى حل سياسي شامل يقوم على
اسس ومرجعيات الحل الشامل وهي هي
المرجعيات المتفق عليها محليا واقليميا
ودوليا
وهو مطار الشعب اليمني ومطلب مجتمع
الاقليمي والدولي وبالتالي نحن مع هذه
الجهود وندعمها
ونحن منذ وقت مبكر وليس من اليوم ولكن
كانت الميليشيات الحوثيه الارهابيه دائما
ترفض
عمليه السلام ولا زالت حتى هذه اللحظه
تهدد بالعوده الى الحرب
وتقيم وتقوم بحشد مقاتليها في الجبهات
وتقوم بانشاء المراكز الصيفيه اللي
بتسميها مراكز صيفيه ومراكز الاستقطاب
المجندين للجبهات
واما نحن فنحن دعاه سلام ولكن نحن في
النهايه في حاله فرض علينا
الحرب سوف يضطر الشعب اليمني في كل مكان
للدفاع عن مصالحه عن حقوقها المشروعه ما
هي ابرز التحديات التي تحتاجون لمواجهتها
في مرحله بناء السلام خاصه بعد تثبيت
الهدنه هناك تحديات كثيره جدا انا اعتقد
ستكون امامنا وهي مدى استجابه الميليشيات
الحوثيه الارهابيه لمشروع السلام
ولخارطه الطريق التي تبنتها تبنتها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الاخوان الاشقاء
في المملكه لديهم مشروع قاره الطريق
ينبغي ان تستجيب لها هذه الميليشيات
وانت تتخلى عن داعمها
الداعمها الايرانيين
يجب ان يفكروا بمصلحه الشعب اليمني
لانهم غلبوا مصلحات ايران على مصلحه الشعب
اليمني خلال المراحل كلها الماضيه
وبالتالي يجب ان يثبتوا مدام مصداقيتهم في
تغليب مصلحه الشعب اليمني على مصالح ايران
والاستجابه لنداءات السلام البرنامج
السعودي نفذ الكثير من المشاريع منذ
انطلاقه البرنامج عام 2018 في كثير من
المجالات في الصحه في النقل في
التوعيه وغيرها هل هذا هذه المشاريع لبت
احتياجات المواطن اليمني وخففت من هذا
العلم
الاخوان في المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
الواقع
اتجهوا منذ البدايه في خطين متوازيين الخط
الاول هو الخط الغاثي وهذا كان الناس
يحتاج الى مساعده عاجله بسبب اوضاع الحرب
والدمار الذي سببته
وهذا قام فيه مركز الملك سلمان
البرنامج انا اعتبر انه هو نقله نقله
نوعيه من مرحله الاغاثه والمساعدات الى
مرحله التنميه المستدامه اليمنيين اليوم
في حاجه الى تنميه في حاجه الى تنميه
مستدامه اليوم اليمنيين يحتاجوا الى ان
يعتمدوا على انفسهم
وهذا الاعتماد لن
ياتي الا بمساعده الشقه انا البرنامج
اليوم بيساعد اليمنيين على القيام بهذا
الدور
وبالتالي نحن انتقلنا اليوم من مرحله
الاغاثه الانسانيه الى مرحله التنميه
المستدامه المتمثل بالبرنامج السعودي
فنحن يعني
نقدم الشكر والتقدير لهادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز والى
ولي عهده سمو الامير محمد بن سلمان على
هذا العمل المتواصل
والانتقال من مرحله اللغات الانسانيه الى
مرحله التنميه المستدامه وهذا ما نحتاجه
في اليمن اليوم وانا اعتقد
النتائج المباشره وغير المباشره لهذه
البرامج التنمويه مشاهده اليوم في كل مكان
مشاهده في التعليم مشاهده في الصحه مشاهده
في المطار اليوم احنا دشرنا المرحله
الثانيه من المطار ووضعنا حجر الاساس
للمرحله الثالثه
ليكون المطار مطار دوري يستوعب كل الرحلات
وكل الطيران في العالم فالاثار المباشره
وغير المباشره هي مستمره الاثار المباشره
اليوم لاحظناها في عيون المرضى اللي
زرناهم من الغرف يعني مدى السعاده لدى
المرضى واهاليهم وتخيل لما يكون عندك 500
الف مريض يحصل على العلاج والتطبيب
المجاني سنويا تغير 500 الف اسره
في السنه تستفيد من هذه من هذا المستشفى
في ظل الدعم المتواصل والطلب دائما لابد
من دعم مجلس القياده الرئاسيه الحكومه
المواطن يتساءل هل بالامكان ايضا ايقاف
الفساد
المستشري داخل بعض المؤسسات اني لم يقل
اغلب المؤسسات
للاستفاده من هذه
الاموال التي تاتي من الخارج وايضا الدعم
المقدم للاشقه والاصدقاء اخي
العزيزات الدوله
وتنتهي مؤسسات دوله تماما
هل هي كارثه لاي شحن من الشعوب ونحن اليوم
بدانا نعيد من هذه المؤسسات
واعدنا بناء المؤسسات هذه بعد ثمان سنوات
من الحرب
وبالتالي تخيل الاعباء الكبيره التي
ستواجهها والتحديات التي تواجه اي حكومه
واي مجلس القياده الرئاسي نحن اليوم فعلنا
مجلس فعلنا الجهاز المركزي الرقابه
والمحاسبه
عندنا تنظيم القضاء شكلنا مجلس القضاء ما
كانش كان القضاء متوقف لمده اكثر من سنه
وسبعه اشهر توقف عن العمل
اعدنا تنظيم المجلس القضاء الاعلى المحاكم
النيابات اعدنا ترتيبات الاوضاع الامنيه
ايضا في عدن والمحافظات الاخرى لانه لا
تستطيع ان تقيم العداله او تكافئ على
الفساد الا بمؤسسات قضائيه وبمؤسسات امنيه
ومؤسسات رقابيه احنا لدينا اليوم الجهاز
المركزي الرقابه والمحاسبه ثم لدينا
النيابه ثم لدينا ايضا
[موسيقى]
القضاء والمحاكم ولدينا ايضا الرقابه من
قبل مجلس النواب اليوم مجلس النواب يقوم
بدورها الرقابي يشكل اللجان
للنزول الميداني لفحص كل
القضايا والمشكلات التي تثار حولها الكثير
من قضايا متعلقه بالفشل السؤال الاخير
مسارات السلام المنشوده في اليمن اذا كانت
في البدايه من في وقف الحرب والهدنه ماذا
بعد هذه الهدنه الى ان ستصل
العمليه السياسيه الهدى نحن جربناها
جربناها اكثر من مره
الهدن هذه عباره كان يستخدمها
الارهابيه استخدمها استراحه محاربه لاعداد
نفسها لمزيد من
لمزيد من الاعتداءات ومزيد من الحروب
وبالتالي نحن نتكلم بشكل واضح يجب ان يكون
هناك وقف انطلاق نار دائم وبرقابه سواء
رقابه دوليه اقليميه محليه يجب ان يكون
هناك اتفاق شامل للحل السياسي الشامل اما
الهدن المؤقته هذه هي استراحه محارب ونحن
جربناها وبالتالي اليوم المشروع المشروع
مشروع المبادره السعوديه للسلام انا اعتقد
انه يتضمن
[موسيقى]
يتضمن اطلاق الاسرى الكل مقابل الكل يتضمن
فتح الطرقات بما في ذلك بمقدمتها طرق تعز
المحاصره منذ ثمان سنوات فتح الطرق بشكل
عام
كل القضايا هذه مطروحه وبالتالي نحن امام
تحديات تحديات كبيره
والكره في ملعب الميليشيات الحوثيه
الارهابي اما نحن فنحن دعاه سلام دائما
المواطن اليمني يطالب السلام والسلام هو
اليوم المطلب الحقيقي لوقف الحرب والدمار
الذي اشعلتها الحوثي في كل ارجاء اليمن في
نهايه هذا اللقاء لا يسعني الا ان اشكركم
سياده رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسيه
الدكتوره شادي العليمي على هذه المقابله
شكرا شكرا لكم
وايضا اشكركم انتم مشاهدينا الكرام على
حسن المتابعه الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات